wassup reject nation it's been a while
since we checked out a new rockstars
video and if it's going to be easter
eggs breakdown who better than them
for morbius all those references with
the minor ones that we already caught
during our trailer reaction but those
were minor this is 20 minutes long you
know there's a lot more things to mine
from there as voss is just chiseling
away at that trailer excited check this
out guys let's see what's in store hit
that like button if you end up enjoying
our reaction let's do it
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of
everything that you might have missed in
the new morbius trailer which packs in
non-stop marvel easter eggs on every
visible surface really the best hype man
for a vampire trying to get into an mcu
party i don't know if i should let him
in it looks like he wants to suck my
blood yeah sure but he's friends with
multiple spiderman spiderman villains
spiderman newspapers spiderman
skyscrapers and he gets a tanned beefy
bot out of nowhere like spiderman did so
you gotta let him in okay whatever i'm
sure i won't regret this enough there is
so much to break down not just the
biggest
you into this studio's bigger plan for
how all of these titles may be connected
to the mcu and spider-man no way home so
let's get started
do you need a doctor
i need a doctor the trailer opens with a
helicopter lifting morbius and some
equipment into a remote jungle island
that chopper's numbered in 9747p
which is actually a common stock
registration number seen on aircraft in
a lot of movies cars 2 casino royale
it's really the bart the bear of movie
aircraft numbers it's like 5 5 5 for
telephone numbers
interesting i learned a new fact today
alan smithy if you hate your work anyway
this pilot kindly asks if he needs a
doctor but dr michael morbius is like if
you dude i am a doctor okay jeez this
paints morbius as a determined but
abrasive intellect a physician in spite
of himself unable to find a better
doctor to fix his ailment yes a doctor
in the vein of doctor strange may be
soon literally in his veins
i should have died
rare for him today
people all over the world have my
disease i'm here
to find a cure so in the comics dr
michael morbius has a rare blood
disorder that he tries to correct with
vampire bat serum and electro therapy
that turns him into a living vampire who
isn't technically the immortally undead
variety since his powers came from
science not the bite of a vampire he was
introduced as a spider-man villain who
also ends up tying in with blade i just
want to pause and say really quick a lot
of people who have been going out there
are saying that they think that this is
going to set up blade
oh no
no way
don't let this get your hopes up all
right they're only doing this with
marvel sony all that crossover because
they have to marvel's gonna do blade on
their own i understand comics
correlations believe me i do but it's
not gonna happen in this we flash back
to morbius as a younger man in a ward
with other children with medical
conditions actually the first trailer
showed this same room with michael and
only one other kid a blonde boy who i
think is going to end up growing up to
be met matt smith
who will have a similar condition curing
it in a similar way giving him vampiric
powers making him a parallel figure
villain of the story i think it's so
interesting how we haven't gotten much
of mats it's been like the same shot of
matt smith in both trailers and he's
probably going to be the central villain
or he's going to turn like villains so
you get your big bad finale at the very
end yeah so they can have their classic
my powers or your powers fight yeah
exactly i'd love to see more of them
though it's weird that they're keeping
them so concealed unless they have
surprises
no no surprises
actually in that other shot the ward was
completely empty aside from those two as
michael set up a game of chess probably
metaphorically setting up the mental
game of chess between the hero and
villain but also suggesting that all
these other kids might have died off or
maybe they're just playing outside yeah
yeah can that be it please
yes crown becomes the villain hunger
with his own vampiric powers but this is
not to be confused with hunger the
devourer of realities that's the
universal scale parasitic force from the
jim starlin thanos comics it's a
completely different thing lots of
things can be hungry folks like matt
smith isn't playing a marble eating
hippo adult michael is cared for by alex
see that is
and we see his more vulnerable gentler
side a doctor trying to cure not only
himself but others all over the world
including sweet little anna here who
draws pictures of a sun over the ocean
with a second son behind it making a
silly emoji face she's the best and
importantly she knows there are multiple
realities with multiple sillier worlds
colliding with each other so save her dr
morbius we need her she's the key
take the risks
if you're gonna run
do it now
morbius slices his hand as he stands
inside this cage with harp-like wires
that in the overhead shot of the swarm
you can see glowing blue meaning it's
emitting a special frequency that
attracts these bats it's not the blood
that's drawing them in it's the
frequency this actually might remind me
of cooper trying to attract the shark in
jaws by putting himself in a cage in the
water you go in the cage cage goes in
front of the cave bats in the cave
there dr michael
moving on
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months then you were found on a
container ship that washed up off a long
island
now the music in this trailer is the
doors people are strange a song that
also features prominently in the vampire
film the lost boys jim morrisons
dr morbius now feels as a living vampire
but we also cannot help but draw a
connection between the strange folks
currently tampering with reality in a
way that might have caused these
multiversal incursions tyrese gibson's
playing science
but in the comics a vampire hunter who
tries to hunt him down wow look how much
they changed our boy ah woke
wow getting woke he just looks like a
dick tracy character
[Laughter]
oh my goodness oh tyrese is really
bringing his own flavor here this is not
just like hey you changed the race i
would like to see the six degrees of
separation that got us from this
depiction
hell you could say the same thing with
jared leto played michael morbius this
container ship incident may be based on
morbius's origin and the amazing
spider-man 101 when he slaughtered
everyone aboard a ship and horrified by
his actions actually tried to commit
suicide but it didn't work and you gotta
love that classic horror imagery here
some blood dripping on the hand from the
monster above this kind of thing we've
seen in silence of the lambs jurassic
world this also reminds me a lot of
aliens but this may remind you of the
blood dripping from peter parker's oh my
gosh blood drop in cinema history
but instead made the loudest splat ever
[Music]
next clip what did you do to yourself
doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying
more live than ever so in the new york
skyline is the horizon building horizon
labs is from the spider-man comics this
is a facility where peter parker tinkers
on his iron spider armor later leading
to the alchemix corporation which is how
we get spider-man 2099 miguel o'hara but
also in the comics peter parker takes dr
morbius here this could be a place where
maybe the two people meet but they do
include the rising sun logo here which
could be connected to those rising suns
of anna's drawings i'm obsessed with
these could she be a horizon test
subject suffering from an experiment
gone awry it's all connected now here
the horizon building is not far from
another building that is i hope it is
for yourself you know from the other
nighttime skyline shot there's the under
construction tower right beside the
oscorp building now we last saw ozcorp
tower in the amazing spider-man 2 in
2014 the andrew garfield mark webb
series and it has the same exact oscorp
logo that broken r in the incomplete p
that actually kind of makes it look like
a question mark evoking the mysterious
nature of this company but of course
that tower had a different structure and
had the word oscorp running up the side
of it not at the top like this so in a
way this is both a nod to the andrew
garfield universe but also in a
completely different form i don't know
maybe oscorp is expanding by acquiring
various shell ventures lots of the city
skyline just to give corporate backing
for all kinds of spidey adjacent
villains that sony plans to roll out
like black cat and rhino and craven
hunter actually we know from a set photo
from this movie that there's going to be
a craven catering truck somewhere
[Music]
okay so that's cooler planets are
craving the hunter yeah yeah i didn't
have no idea about that coijandro was in
our trailer reaction he got a lot of
crap in the comments for saying that
that's a different one than the one the
amazing spider-man uh-oh yes same logo
different building some people might
still go but it's the same logo it's
gotta be the same one like you would
have to have built a brand new building
and have to build a brand new logo like
if they use the same design they'd have
to rebuild it and put it up at the top
it's not the same one from amazing
spider-man the logo is just in reference
to it but it's not the same building
unless they bought another building and
they just put their logo on yeah they
could have done that but either way it's
definitely not that as futuristic you
know and even the way the oz corp sign
is realized on that original building is
in different materials exactly at least
exactly not the same exact building i do
find it interesting how like this movie
seems to be exploring more of the
science areas that we've seen peter
parker tamper with before more than the
peter parker movies
a lot of movies are doing spider-man
things more than the recent spider-man
movies oddly enough so it seems like
sony's suggesting morbius could be
taking place in a kind of merged shared
universe perhaps on the other side of
doctor strange's spell in spider-man no
way home but my issue is morbius was
originally intended to come out like a
year before no way home was going to at
least certainly before venom's reality
warped teleportation in the let there be
carnage post-credits scene really i
think the easiest way to interpret this
cause and effect logic is that the
multiverse has already been merged in
various chaotic ways that we just
haven't noticed before doctor strange's
spell and no way home that wasn't what
broke it lots of things have been
causing these incursions and that was
just the final straw that broke the
camel's back because we did learn in
loki that according to kang time is a
flat circle what we understood to be
cause and effect really just needs to be
thrown out the window essentially the
multiverse is destined to scramble and
therefore will have always been
scrambled that's something that coy was
bringing up to us not long ago that the
multiverse has already been colliding
hence that's why we had j jonah jameson
already in the post credit scene four
far from home yeah and i think that
seems to be something a lot of people
overlook some people probably just chalk
that up to the fact that oh it's just
they got jk simmons back but he's
playing a different version of j jonah
jameson perhaps i still think it's an
indicator though in physics this concept
is called pascal's omelette let's move
on it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do so morbius releases
sonar bursts like a bat does i like how
from its perspective it causes the
surfaces to swirl with this fluid smoky
texture transforming walls and floors
from hard surfaces that would hurt his
fragile body if he were smack into them
to now a more amorphous environment that
you can just kind of float through on
morbius chalkboard are some letters
referring to the base pairs and a dna
protein strain but actually to the left
is written pkb37 pkb 49 etcetera etc
these are actually all weights of silver
silver is of course a weakness to
werewolves and a lot of vampire fiction
to vampires as well perhaps morbius was
testing what weights of silver have the
strongest effect on him now or maybe
he's starting to realize that he has
vampire abilities but morbis is not
prone to the same type of vampire
weaknesses that a typical vampire is
prone to maybe we'll get a little bit of
a like during a montage of him figuring
stuff out of him trying like i'm gonna
taste some garlic yeah look at the
mirror yeah go hold across yeah and see
if any of that will make him weak but
come to find out that
nah he's fine but he'll glow in the day
and then on his desk in front of him is
an open textbook on bats and an empty
blood bag michael morbius did you just
sip blood out of that boba tea straw
tube and then he lifts a massive stone
tomb you know these things that medical
doctors leave lying around their offices
and then he booms his echo location
city you can see it's honing in on this
green and red skylight window it's hard
to tell what building this is but it
does give off some kind of red glow on
the rubik's building as the burst passes
it making me think this could be the
horizon building that has a similar red
glow but there's also a tall
construction crane to the upper left so
this might be near that under
construction tower beside oscorp really
i just think morbius's final battle will
go down with luxie's crown and his
allies at oscorp and or horizon maybe to
retrieve a serum that can help patients
like anna next clip
[Music]
okay here morbius wearing his orange
prisoner jumpsuit so i'm guessing this
is part of his escape from police
custody uses his powers in a subway
tunnel you'd see the sonic energy
flowing past him as he's in a wind
tunnel his earlobes wrinkle over like
those of a bat i suppose which looks
like they're reacting to the sound but
it's worth noting that our earlobes
aren't the part of our body or bat
anatomy that absorbs the sound through
the tissue that is actually the inner
ear an auditory nerve mammal ears have
these funnel and cone shapes to direct
sound inward but whatever i guess the
wrinkling makes them look more bat-like
and you know so much eric you can see
someone running after him on the
platform it looks like al madrigal's
character fbi agent rodriguez but it
also does match the shot of matt smith
later on in the trailer on this train
platform he might be in this location
too i'm wondering if this sequence might
play out like the new york subway scene
in the movie ghosts remember when
patrick swayze finally learns to channel
his undead powers and i just mentioned
ghosts because it is really the only
film i can think of to successfully mix
the tones of supernatural horror with
comedy and action and romance and
morality play as this movie morbius
living vampire is the next ghost oh my
god that scene in ghost with vincent
schiavelli is that tragic subway ghost
terrifying his mental breakdown just
that's a mephisto doing a chef's kiss
because the movies and tv shows haunt my
dreams and ruin my sleep
[Music]
here we see morbius in a blood bank
resisting the urge to guzzle it all down
now notice the audio of morbius's line
sounds a bit edited there's something
inside of him who wants to hunt and
consume blood yeah someone stop it edit
it sounds like the words consume blood
was spoken by another character almost
like crown finishing morbius's sentence
for him because he's also a vampire next
clip and you controlled it
half the city wants to kill you we
haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco the great
jared harris appears as michael's mentor
figure perhaps the character emile nicos
from the comics who is part of dr
morby's past as a kid from greece this
is this crime scene from that subway
station overseen by agent stroud and
rodriguez with these dead patrol
officers yikes i'm thinking morbius
could have fled into the subway when he
escaped but then crown might have killed
these cops to make it look like it was
morbius and did this also to hide his
own vampiric powers i feel like he's 100
right about that but i was hoping that
it would actually be morpheus did it he
like lost control i feel like that'd be
a more challenging film to get on board
with an actual anti-hero pursuit he's
having a difficult time controlling his
urges imagine the psychological struggle
he'd be going through that's my concern
about this movie they're not really
going to do that yeah it's going to be
exactly here
easy for you to get on board possible
yeah don't make the anti-heroes be too
villainous but i hope for your version i
i i'll be pleasantly surprised if they
go more towards what i'm hoping for
versus the very predictable route but
then the big detail morbius reads a
daily bugle newspaper with the same
print edition masthead from the sam
raimi spider-man movies and from venom
let there be carnage headline dr michael
marbeus apprehended for vampire murder
underneath in a shocking turn of events
world-renowned medical genius dr michael
morbius has been arrested for murder and
then above it three teaser headlines
finding the truth within told in his own
words rhino on the loose zoo hoax fools
us all and black cat friend or foe
something i didn't realize before
because when i saw rhino and looks like
okay this is saying it's time to the
amazing spider-man universe actually you
know that the rhino and amazing
spider-man is this big like mecca rhino
so it has to be a rhino and i'm sure
eric's going to go into this and i'm
just trying to get something in here
before he says
if you're saying
zoo hoax fooled us all it could be that
this is different rhino one who actually
has more of the traditional suits
where he could fool people thinking it's
an actual rhino that would be fun so it
was probably a different rhino now you
can definitely read these as teases for
the existence of spider-man villain
black cat felicia hardy in this universe
party was actually played by felicity
jones in the 2014 film and sony has been
planning a black cat spin-off movie for
years and then of course spider-man
villain rhino who was played by paul
giamatti as a man in an armored suit in
the 2014 film though this headline
reports it as a zoo hoax i don't know
what that is so it might just be a wink
for us but i am sorry to do this but as
a nerd with a journalism degree this
newspaper is straight-up
was a tabloid with a splashier full
photo cover with inlay block text of
course a parody of the new york post
this version has the classic serious
journalism six column layout more text
based like the new york times with a
serif text headline above the photo yet
despite this more serious design the
wording is full of bad practices even j
jonah jameson wouldn't allow dr michael
morbius apprehended for vampire murder
is grammatically nonsensical is it
saying orbeez murdered a vampire or is
himself a vampire who murdered someone
or murdered someone in the way a vampire
would i'm sorry but these are the
details newspaper editors are obsessed
with j jonah jameson would totally be
like way too many words use two or three
max like you would never waste six
columns of ink on a long vague verb like
apprehended when actually ethically
journalists are supposed to use verbs
like arrested or charged for active
investigations and definitely not put
the word murder in the headline even
when quoted by presumably police you
wouldn't report his name as dr dr
michael morbius in the headline and then
in the lower graph the full word doctor
michael morbius i mean really a more
appropriate headline would be something
like nobel winning doctor arrested under
charges of vampire-like killings which
is more clear and obviously more
scandalous right because he has one of
nobel you would put that in the headline
and then you would print his name in the
lead sentence of the article i know i
know movies are filled with professional
inaccuracies sure sure but every time
the daily bugle had shown up in a sony
movie they have been weirdly fixated on
the whole media industry side of it like
let there be carnage is all about toxic
relationships between true crime
reporters and their subjects in the
rainy trilogy jj jones jameson
absolutely pushes overly salacious
headlines but that is something that
happens in the real world the new york
post totally does that but at the same
time he also lectures peter parker on
lighter in fact as a kid that's where
he's first learning the difference
between libel and slander and then the
third movie he totally fires eddie
slanders plagiarism and goes to the
length of printing a retraction and then
far from home that makes the daily bug a
direct parody of alex jones info wars
i'm just saying that when it comes to
whatever these movies want to say about
journalism they normally put a ton of
thought into the way they depict the
daily bugle but here i'm like christ you
couldn't even reduce the kerning between
the b and the a
anyway i'm just saying maybe this slop
could have been an intentional rush job
like the bugle could have been forced to
rush this front page out under pressure
from corporate interests in order to
ruin it dr michael morbius's reputation
as much as possible as quickly as
possible wow journalistic integrity
journalistic accuracy
my goodness mr vos you have blown my
mind i saw you going off about it on
twitter but man this breakdown here is
is some
juicy juicy deets i must say i think
this is my favorite sidebar rant of any
breakdown all year if we can do deep
fakes sony if you're watching it's not
too late to change your headline around
but you can change the newspaper around
it's not gonna take you a long time give
it a shot be the cheapest shot you pay
for in the entire booth you could
digitally do it yeah let's go ahead and
do it he also really did open my eyes
something i never noticed was the
attention to detail on just the
headlines something that you can kind of
overlook it's super specific it creates
another life to the moments when they do
flash up on screen especially for like
the peter parker situations and the remy
films because he's a photographer
working at the daily bugle so he needs
to have that pump it needs to have that
impact uh but yeah i mean
yeah i agree it's weird man not bothered
by it
you didn't go to journalism it was the
only difference and then this park where
morbius was meeting with jared harris's
character he's now swarmed by police and
here stroud wears a kind of bionic
enhancement on his arm maybe something
that assists with his vampire hunting
like retractable wooden steak claws or i
don't know with that tubing maybe
something that could extract morbius's
blood then raise garlic juice being in
san francisco likely referring to the
events of the first venom film set in
san francisco remember that when the
light foundation was exposed for human
testing using alien goo but i don't know
if this universe is connected to the mcu
or even other spider verses would that
crime really be the biggest event these
fbi agents would be referencing over the
past few years i mean depending on how
deep in the mcu this movie's going to
try to be we did have a freaking blip
and then arguably even bigger in san
francisco you had giant man swimming
around in the bay and ant-man the wasp
you had buses flying all over the street
in shanghai which we know from the
social media that movie was a viral
event but here stroud finds an origami
bat i'm just going to kind of call it
left behind by morbius at the sights of
his good deeds but it looks like it was
folded from a note containing his
chemical equations from his lab maybe a
message for the agents that he wants him
to find moving on
hey dr mike you and i should stay in
touch
to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
morbius flees past graffiti of
spider-man with murderer written on it
now this spider-man was actually a
throwback to the tobey maguire era suit
from the ps4 game loading screen
murderer though would imply the mcu
peter parker who in no way home is
facing public scrutiny and accusations
that he murdered mysterio but like this
movie's references to venom and to the
oscorp logo design it's just more
evidence suggesting that morbius is
taking place in some fusion of all of
these realities and that's especially
true for the big cameo by michael keaton
as adrian tombs vulture still in his
white jumpsuit from the spider-man
homecoming post-credits scene which of
course is in the mcu so i guess this
movie's implication is when venom
transported into the mcu in the let
there be carnage post-credits scene he
now exists in a reality where venom has
always existed as tom hardy eddie brock
something that people know and that
could be the sony's way of explaining
how it is that alfred molina doc just
knows tom holland peter and how michael
keaton vulture knows dr mike here either
way i do like how the police lights
flash red and blue on their faces the
color of the webhead hero that whips
them together you know that is
it
it is baffling that they were going to
release this one before no way hope when
you look at the trailer for no way home
it would look like there are
implications that are happening in that
trailer that could help answer some of
this mishmash that's going on in this
trailer but the fact that this was going
to come out before then
and i'm not even under the impression
this movie's gonna even try to explain
itself no it's just gonna let these
things exist without even explaining it
i mean i could see it being that way and
maybe as they you know further their
sony spider-man universe they'll start
to address it but yeah i mean looking at
all the lead up to the multiverse we've
had so far it actually seems like a
happy accident that they should have to
remix it this way yes because yeah the
venom setup is so deliberate and then
obviously you got spider-man no way home
which is like the deep dive into really
unpacking this and then maybe by the
time we understand it we won't have to
warn her so much while watching this
movie then morbius is fired upon by
guards bullets that morbius dodges
matrix style this actually looks like it
could be part of an extended kingsman
style long take that goes in and out of
slow motion meets nightcrawler you save
lives you don't take them
your hippocratic oath
or to destroy it
okay stroud appears to be talking
morbius down while he holds his neck
suggesting he was either just swiped
there or maybe even bitten on his neck
then there's this nurse who pleased and
feared on a corridor and in one of the
flashes of light you can see a grey claw
grabbing her neck that's not more basis
but it also could be the vampiric form
of crown moving on
money shot him
okay a massive swarm of bats fills the
space at first the camera is actually
shown from the point of view of one of
those bats and then at the center of it
all is morbius's form you can actually
see a glimpse of purple behind him
probably part of his classic purple cape
from the comics and then we see
morbius's nasty boy roar it looks like
he's got some fresh blood on his teeth
telling us that he might have just taken
a bite out of something or someone let's
hope it was crime and the title which
like all the title texts in this trailer
has its inner light force lowered until
it turns red drained like blood from a
vampire bite and then on to the last
clip
[Music]
who the hell are you mad i
am
just kidding it's dr michael morvious at
your service okay morby spoils what
looks like a counterfeiting operation
you can see large printers and hundred
dollar bill designs on the screens
morpheus is impersonating venom here so
we must be aware of that lethal
protector from the west coast and how he
delivers vigilante justice with that
terrifying monster face wink i guess
it's their equivalent of uh
i can't pull it off now in terms of
world logic it's just another curveball
right i mean i don't know has this
morbius met venom or is venom just like
a famous vigilante in this world that
people like to quote am i wasting my
time questioning cinematic universe
continuity when the studio thinks you
can just reverse engineer this all with
graffiti a few jokes the newspaper and
throwing money at michael keaton i don't
know like folks i think the doors had it
right people are strange no you are 100
right because as like humorous as it was
when i first said it it did bring up
questions of like
why would he
do that
why specifically that character why
specifically like so close to these like
i don't know how how aware how
nationwide of a character has venom now
to do like the i am venom thing it
almost seems like it would hurt your
ability to be clanded like it's gonna
bring a lot of unwanted attention your
way because people are going to be able
to look out for venom i mean i know the
quote is we are venom but at the same
time though it's it is like a weird line
to pull he seems to be literally doing a
poor man's impersonation of venom at
that moment yeah so that's what it's
kind of odd to be is like why would he
know that
yeah maybe in this version uh you know
venom's got like a web series or
something like that web series
hey you can support new rock stars by
checking out our merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com you can follow me on
instagram and twitter avos follow new
rockstars and subscribe for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
word to your mother ah i miss new rock
stars
i mean
i still watch plenty of these this is
reacting
with all of you yeah it's that much more
special but guys thank you so much for
being here subscribe to nr if you
haven't done so already you can
subscribe to us hit like buttons last
but not least let's do a
daniel gallacher it's only logical that
on a michael morbius video breakdown do
a little breakdown of you because
there's so many easter eggs in your life
you could easily end up a spider-man
villain you're already on the trajectory
to a john shout out and hey man you work
with chemicals you work with you know
viruses and substances and whatnot but
what's your secret what are you trying
to cure within yourself that will
eventually lead you to mutating into the
loch ness monster that's your super hero
anti-villain character you know you grow
tentacles and whatnot and you can
dispense justice with a heaping helping
of salt lake water not salt lake city
like in utah but you know i assume
there's probably some salt content in
the lake water where the loch ness
monster lives this is the best shout out
you've ever received i hope you do it
well buddy and we'll catch you on the
next one stay pledged and uh much love
that's how you use this minute like
michael morbius you like to suck that's
right the life out of a room